notre reporter lille a famous où elle
lit la fab jour alors qu'elle est à
l'atmosphère instinct a coûté olivier
l'atmosphère est beaucoup plus détendue
que ce à quoi on s'attendait la
manifestation s'est terminée il ya à
peine quelques minutes avec le départ
d'assad traoré la third adama traoré
pour tout vous dire en réalité on
craignait aussi un affrontement en tout
cas un face à face au très musclé entre
d'un côté le comité justice pour adama
et de l'autre côté le 5 le syndicat de
police alliance puisque la raison des
tensions d'aujourd'hui entre les deux
parties c'est la fresque murale qui se
trouve juste derrière moi qu'ils
représentent
djordje floyd et adama traoré alors ce
n'est pas cette fresque on soit d'après
ce que le syndicat policier dit qui pose
problème les biens l'inscription qu'il
ya au dessus de cette fresque contre le
racisme et contre les violences
policières une inscription qui a
provoqué la colère des policiers qui ont
l'impression finalement encore une fois
c'est une façon de les stigmatiser de
stigmatiser la police républicaine et de
les accuser tous deux un racisme alors à
sa traoré qui arrivait ici a pris la
parole et elle a dénoncé dans cette
volonté d'effacer cette inscription la
volonté des forces de l'ordre d' oublier
de faire oublier en tout cas le visage
et le nom de son frère mais aussi de
toutes les victimes de violences
policières proposer l'écouté
à chaque fois qu'un mouvement des
syndicats de police en france va venir
bafouée va venir salir la mémoire de nos
morts repeindre le visage de un homme
mort de 1 à nos frères on reviendra
encore plus nombreux et ils ont reculé
aujourd'hui on peut appeler ça comme une
victoire c'est une victoire pour nous
que le fait que alliance ne viennent pas
sur place pour repeindre ne serait-ce
que même une lettre comme je vous le
disais ah ça traoré qui est parti il ya
quelques minutes alors elles étaient
accueillies ici quand elle est arrivée
comme comme une star elle a été
ovationnée on va demander des
autographes il y avait énormément de
jeunes de ce quartier populaire qui
l'ont accueilli effectivement comme une
star et c'est vrai que cette
impopularité
convoi grandissante lors des
rassemblements dassa traoré se distingue
beaucoup du malaise des forces de
l'ordre qui voulaient se rassembler ici
qui ont finalement décidé de se
retrouver devant la préfecture de la
seine-saint-denis à bobigny et des
forces de l'ordre qui ont l'impression
réellement d'être sous le feu des
critiques depuis plusieurs semaines et
qui ont l'impression d'être totalement
abandonnés et pas du tout soutenu par
leur ministre christophe castaner merci
beaucoup lit la fois pour toutes ces
précisions lit la femme ouzou en direct
de stains